good morning John hear me out
what if people are almost all pretty
good and they're just trying to make
things better for themselves and the
people they love in a world that has a
whole lot of directional inertia what if
we're all trying to do that in countries
that have tens or hundreds of millions
of people who all see the world a little
differently from each other what if
there are a bunch of leaders who have to
try and figure out how to move forward
while listening to the wants and needs
and hopes and dreams and frustrations
and fears of thousands or millions of
people and what if this might be a
stretch those people are mostly big bags
of well-meaning worry trying to do the
right thing when it's never clear what
the right thing to do is something weird
has happened to me in the last couple of
weeks and it's the result of I think
three different things first is that I
finished this book it's called high
conflict it talks about how good and
important conflict is until it's not
anymore until the moment when people
start being much more concerned about
winning the conflict than solving the
problems that spurred the conflict of in
the first place how to recognize when
that's happening and how to walk back
from it if it isn't achieving the goals
the second thing that happened is of
course last week I spent a huge amount
of time trying to understand on a deep
level a large piece of legislation and
how complicated it is and how important
it is and how good it is even though it
has parts of it in it that I would
rather definitely not be there in doing
that I got a better idea of all of the
coalitions that had to come together to
form some kind of solidarity if not
consensus about this then at least buy
it you had to take a lot of different
kinds of people with some broad
alignments about big stuff but a ton of
individual disagreement and get them on
board for something very complex and big
and meaningful the third thing is that a
friend of mine died his name was John
Engen he was the mayor of my town for
the last 15 years long time what I know
about him and all of the people I've
ever seen work in my city government
either elected or Not Elected did is
that they have very hard jobs in which
they have to listen to a lot of people
and then end up doing stuff that makes
no one happy because their job isn't to
make one group of people happy it's to
represent everyone and nothing really
hits their desk unless people disagree
about it I disagree really really deeply
with a lot of people in my community and
I'm sure that privately mayor ingen
hated when he was hated and there were a
lot of people who did not like him as we
do with politicians and I'm sure that he
was often very frustrated that despite
lots of training and his best efforts
people still would not hear him
sometimes but he understood that the
first line on the job description of
being a leader was not be heard it was
listen for him the first step in being
heard was to listen to make sure that
people were heard so that they would be
more likely to hear him I think leaders
all around the world do this and we have
no mechanism to celebrate that or to
thank them for it it is very very hard
and very important work it's been hard
to not be be cynical about government
for a while now maybe forever but
thinking some about the mechanisms for
how conflict functions deeply examining
some legislation that took a lot of work
to build alignment on and of course
having caused to examine the life of a
really dedicated and talented public
servant has put my brain in a different
space at least for the moment which has
made me feel really good about a thing
that we've been doing a really long time
called how to vote in every state it's a
YouTube channel and also now a tick tock
account where you can go and watch the
video for your state it'll tell you how
to get registered whether you can vote
from home how to get a sample ballot how
to find your polling place all the stuff
you need to make your plan so that you
can go and vote because voting as I said
on Twitter is the butt wiping of
democracy it doesn't solve all the
problems and it's not the limit of what
you should do but it's pretty low lift
and it definitely does not help to not
do it so if you or someone you know
doesn't have a voting plan for this
election check it out or send it to them
thank you John feel better I'll see you
on Tuesday